[Music]
foreign
dressed up is still a monkey
[Music]
don't put your trust in Fortune until
you are in heaven
he who boasts of his accomplishments
will he ridicule on himself
children who get everything they ask for
seldom succeed in life
[Music]
wealth can be acquired Beauty cannot
there is no bitter crust to a hungry
person
every road leads somewhere
enough Little Raindrops a river could
overflow
boldness is the fruit of Hope
loyalty is more valuable than diamonds
a wise man doesn't see his foot on the
ground he watches his next step
what good is something big that you
don't have if there is something small
that is in your hands
[Music]
the person who airs should be corrected
not made fun of
[Music]
postponed today's anger until tomorrow
a young Branch can be straightened a
mature one breaks
[Music]
it is never too late to offer anything
that is good
[Music]
the higher the bamboo the more it can be
bent
[Music]
the empty can makes a lot of noise
good character is true beauty that never
fades
you does not look back to his Origins
will never reach his destination
[Music]
the prepared person beats the
hard-working person
marriage is not a porridge that you can
spit out if it's too hot
the pain in the little finger is felt by
the whole body
it is easy to be born it is difficult to
be a human being
when the blanket is short learn to bend
your body
the fly on the back of a water buffalo
thinks that it's taller than the buffalo
no man is brave in the presence of a
crying woman
borrowed clothes are either too tight or
too loose
he who speaks too much works too little
A desperate person will even hold on to
a knife edge
every kind of animal can be tamed but
not the tongue of man
nothing destroys iron except its own
rust
[Music]
the Earth has ears news has wings
if you make a habit of buying things you
do not need you will soon be selling
things you do need
life is like a wheel sometimes at the
top sometimes at the bottom
there is no earthly Bliss not watered by
Tears
don't rush things to get better results
be like a rice stock the more grains it
Bears the lower it bows
not all that is black is charcoal
the real hero doesn't say that he is one
a diligent person will soon prosper
[Music]
what goes up must come down
the bitterness of studying is preferable
to the bitterness of ignorance
it is easier dodama River than stop the
flow of gossip
[Music]
wherever the head goes the tail will
follow
he who refuses advice will end up in
hardship
[Music]
there's no glory without sacrifice
if a bamboo tube makes a loud sound
it is empty
a fly cannot enter a closed mouth
[Music]
lazy people will eventually lose even
their trousers
[Music]
if there is no patience there will be no
food
[Music]
he who believes in hearsay does himself
a disservice
to a dog a bone has more value than a
pearl
he who is choosy often picks the worst
avoiding danger is not cowardice courage
without discretion is useless
whatever you do think about it seven
times before you act
to a person who has real shame words are
his oath
one need not inherit wealth if he if he
inherits good manners
tell a lie and the truth will come to
light
a country without freedom is like a
prisoner with Shackled hands
Beauty will fade but not goodness
he who does not know to look where he
came from will never get to his
destination
some people count other people's faults
but ignore their own
the voluntary Obedience of people
depends on who is commanding them
[Music]
he who sows wind reaps a typhoon
if someone throws a rock at you throw
him bread
Thorns bury themselves shallowly in the
feet of one who walks slowly they bury
themselves deeply into the feet of one
who walks quickly
a brave man will face a situation no
matter how Dreadful
we should always keep in mind that love
hope and faith in God will bring us
success in life
truthfulness ensures a lasting
relationship
people who do not break things first
will never learn to create anything
what one learns in childhood he carries
into adulthood
if it's work do it fast if it's food eat
it little by little
don't empty the water jar until the rain
falls
[Music]
if you save you will have something to
withdraw
a quiet person hides his anger
whatever you borrowed return it so they
will lend it again
[Music]
wherever you find sugar you'll find ants
a fly will not enter a closed mouth
spend lavishly and you will end up with
nothing
regret is always at the end
when there is a difficulty there is also
a relief
[Music]
an undisciplined child will leave his
mother in tears
[Music]
the person who believes in rumors has no
self-confidence
your labor is useless if someone else
sees its fruit
don't count your chicks until the eggs
are hatched
even a log soaked in water will burn if
it is placed near a fire
[Music]
every pot has a matching lid
a debt can be paid but a kind act cannot
[Music]
you cannot pull hair from a bald head
if the bow is sinking the stern follows
[Music]
people gain strength by standing
together
don't count your chicks until the eggs
are hatched
if a stone thrown upward hits you don't
take offense
a sleeping shrimp is carried away by the
current
[Music]
emulate the good ignore the bad
no undertaking is difficult if pursued
with perseverance
to get a girl's attention tell her
something that showcases her unique
perspective or Sparks her curiosity
[Music]
he who takes a lot of risks loses more
than he gains
[Music]
no crime is left unpunished
it is better to joke with a drunkard
than with someone who just woke up